No. I know New York Rangers,
the extra drama doesn't square Darden coming forward. Mozzarella,
almost like headache.
[Inaudible].
Gosh, I'm up levy for tall. One-stop hadn't been able to book it in,
so [inaudible] they only call them
[inaudible] the shoot or the Bruce Springsteen, anything
topped out of my hand or didn't get there that are high or
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh, [inaudible] dog.
[inaudible].
I know. Y'all know the
[inaudible] as I say
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] uh [inaudible].
So do you want to call it? [inaudible].
[Inaudible] uh, [inaudible].
Let us Sue E in New York Rangers. What else? Them.
And then I don't mind.
[Inaudible] uh, the, uh, Gloria
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] um,
[inaudible] uh
[inaudible] um,
[inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
The King, the clerk
[inaudible] Rangers or someone saw our country
borders basis.
[inaudible] tall order.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] instinct on her
Harteau top hot hotter pin. And he
[inaudible] [inaudible] Wars, biggest guys.
[inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] married. It's not arguments that at all that at all.
Okay. And Laura
[inaudible], uh, or the handlebar.
The story of [inaudible], uh, or,
or I think [inaudible],
um,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh.
Or they make you like this now you're Maria
[inaudible] you're
[inaudible] [inaudible] Monday then [inaudible] [inaudible].
Where are you from?
[Inaudible] yeah, come on.
[inaudible] thank you.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] so I hardly
[inaudible] that in my garden, so
[inaudible] pretty much owned by
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] at top of my head.
[inaudible] some,
[inaudible] also Hamana and maybe [inaudible]
handshake. [inaudible].
Their sister [inaudible].
[Inaudible] a bit Manasseh.
[inaudible] on dance off feed of him. I get [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Yeah. I like menthol.
[Inaudible] To slot that much.
Brought the
[inaudible].
Yeah. [inaudible].
[Inaudible] uh, [inaudible] uh,
the whole
[inaudible] vibe for
[inaudible] when I was, come on.
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] yes.
But times have changed sometimes they've changed their,
their, um,
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] and
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] this. Laughter
[inaudible] [inaudible].
That? Uh, you N uh, [inaudible] uh, the figure
[inaudible] [inaudible] or value report from the perspective
[inaudible] [inaudible] what else? [inaudible].
[Inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] first are going after and I just walked to the door,
water back then. That one. Wow. Eh, uh, the,
they got an Nevada, um, Medea, some ham
[inaudible] [inaudible] FaceTime I'm uh, um, [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh
[inaudible] um, and he gleamed to know, I got to clock Monday,
Saturday afternoon to quantify the [inaudible] first direct cannon.
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
Yeah. I felt like they were
listening to this SWAT and feeling like you can then put out
[inaudible] so there are tough, man.
They keep it off their. No more
[inaudible] they can improv doesn't. So then the
[inaudible], um, I'll take, uh, Hm.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] uh, hype in New York. Uh, dude never told me live.
Do you wait for me? Yeah.
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].
Wouldn't be [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] and, um, [inaudible].
I take the up, all of it in the mail.
I made it competitive and make it all, uh,
also take it out debate about kudos.
Say in action now, lead sort of a tailor.
So is that okay for that as a high boy?
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh [inaudible] so the hard rain just spill it out
also Harvey, uh, also harvest smart. Yeah.
[inaudible] men.
So then I did not do Marta and just do my side. Yeah. So.
More like the [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations,
please hit subscribe.